i guess we'll have to compare iq tests  and i can tell you who is going to win  you can test too much you do know that  who says that oh just read the manuals  read the books manuals read the book  read the books remote books trump  referred to  seemingly haiti african mostly non-white  countries as [ __ ] countries trump  also tweeting i won this election by a  lot president putin  he just said it's not russia i will say  this i don't see any reason why it would  be he invites a college sports team to  the white house after a big win and he  serves them fast food option number one  with bernie  on the sanders  that's because you socialize medicine  look hey are you still not gonna listen  to them despite the constant negative  press  cobb fefe